time now for morning rounds with CBS
News chief medical correspondent dr. Jon
LaPook and CBS News contributor dr. Tara
narula first up heart health februari is
american heart month a time to remember
heart disease is responsible for the
most deaths each year in the united
states but how well do people understand
it the Cleveland Clinic released a
survey this week that gauged our
knowledge of heart health when it came
to numbers we know off the top of our
heads our weight and our bank account
balance led the way under forty percent
of a thousand people surveyed knew their
blood pressure or their waist
circumference which can be key metrics
in heart health I understand why you
whether the way you forget your waist
circumference I'd prefer to forget but
let's talk about cholesterol levels here
because understanding kelevra
cholesterol levels can be very
complicated with HDL and LDL do people
actually do they understand it no no
they say I need my cholesterol check
didn't really know what the normal
number is or what we talked about we say
HDL LDL triglycerides yeah so in this
survey they found that only twenty-five
percent knew that HDL is the good
cholesterol the protective one only
fifty two percent knew that LDL is the
bad cholesterol one that we worry a lot
about that raises your cardiovascular
risk most Americans think that
triglycerides are the same as
cholesterol which they are not they are
a form of circulating fat in the blood
and only twelve percent knew that you
should start having your cholesterol
checked around the ages of 18 to 24
interesting John we know that
supplements are used to combat or
ameliorate heart health problems yeah a
lot of people are increasingly using
these and the survey found that
two-thirds of the people who were
surveyed used one or more of these
supplements to try to improve their
heart health and yet the American Heart
Association says you know really try to
get all your nutrients from real food
and I spoke to dr. steve nison who's the
head of cardiovascular medicine for the
Cleveland Clinic he said there's really
no good evidence that it does help your
heart health and you know it's a very
typical thing we want to just pop some
pills a lot easier than doing exercise
eating right losing weight all that
stuff on to the next topic our eating
habits continuing with the theme of
heart health a statement was released
this week by the American Heart
Association where
Neil timing and frequency its impact on
preventing heart disease and why
skipping breakfast may not be the way to
go so dr. nurullah breakfast is we're
told is the most important meal of the
day how true is that yes so my mom told
me that I tell my kids and I know some
people dr. Jon LaPook who do not eat
breakfast Americans skip it but in fact
it is very important this research
statement the scientific statement
basically said that breakfast eaters
tend to have lower blood pressure lower
cholesterol better blood sugar
overweight and lower cardiovascular
events the thinking is that maybe by
starting your morning eating breakfast
you're setting a pattern of healthy
habits of eating throughout the rest of
the day you are getting in some needed
nutrients like calcium and fiber and
also it's kind of training or helping
your body better utilize blood sugar so
John I mean what should we keep in mind
then about meal times and meal amount
well I love the research in this review
article really mate one of the things
that was so interesting was defining
what a snack is and what it Emil is just
because you call it a snack doesn't mean
it's not a meal so you may be having
over six depending if they say look
we're gonna device cream as much snack
there and actually they define it they
say if it's more than fifteen percent of
the 15 fifteen percent of the calories
of the day it's a it's emilio all that
snack but generally the general idea is
you're trying to distribute the calories
throughout the day try to avoid eating
late and then again as Tara saying this
evidence about eating breakfast you know
maybe actually have some scientific
basis to it all right all very upsetting
news all right finally today we're
introducing a new segment two morning
rounds that'll air the first week of
every month practical advice will focus
on the health topics everyone deals with
him the first up is emergency room
visits alright these are very disturbing
usually because you're usually in the
state of crisis and the last time I was
in the merge from the guy in the next
bed head it was it was a gunshot victim
so that adds to the connective the drama
Bonnie peso so but so how do you how do
you approach an emergency room visit you
want to try to keep your wits about you
but you definitely want to bring certain
information into the ER with you first
of all a list of your medications and
not just the names but the doses that
you take so that if
ER doctor wants to give you something
else you know if it will interact with
what you're taking a list of your
allergies and also a list of your
doctors not just your primary care but
your specialists and their phone numbers
so that they can be contacted by the ER
right and then in addition to that I
have this idea of a health emergency
buddy yeah so have somebody out there
preferably somebody who knows about
computers who has a document with all of
this information that Tara told you
about I mean what if you're on the beach
and you get knocked down you're on the
way to the emergency room usually you're
going to have access to a phone you call
that buddy and that buddy can one way or
the other email fax carrier pigeon get
that information to the emergency room
it's also nice to have a buddy come with
you to the emergency on because you are
scared you're in pain the information is
going in one ear and out the others and
low-tech have a pencil and a pad write
things down and when you leave the
emergency room make sure you get
instructions yes and make sure you get a
copy of all of the labs that they did
and the testing that you did I have
people come to my office and they say
this is my discharge paperwork and has
one diagnosis on it and nothing else and
they see but I got a chest x-ray and I
had labs done asked for those results
try to get your doctor working on it
from the outside if you have one yeah
outside inside you have the person
coming to you to the hospital they're
there with you and at the same time your
doctor can call the emergency room and
talk to the doctor there and if you want
to make sure you have a follow-up plan
to because the ER is just supposed to be
in and out so lots of times people for
instance might go in with chest pain and
they'll tell them well you didn't have a
heart attack but you need to follow up
and have a stress test or something else
you definitely want that over when you
leave it is not over in over 20 doctors
Jon LaPook and Tara narula thanks for
your time